there was dancing fireworks
and a ballistic missile launch North
Korea brought in the New Year not just
with festivities but also by firing what
it called its super large multiple
rocket launcher officials showed off the
systems on Saturday capping a Six-Day
meeting of the ruling Workers Party in
which they laid out their goals for
2023. Kim Jong-un said 30 such systems
were ready to be deployed to quote
overwhelm the enemy South Korea
Pyongyang also warned it would
significantly increase the production of
tactical nuclear weapons
the current situation highlights the
necessity to mass-produce tactical
nuclear weapons and calls for an
exponential increase of the country's
nuclear Arsenal
North Korea declared itself a nuclear
estate in September calling its program
irreversible and not up for negotiation
in announcements made on Sunday a new
intercontinental ballistic missile
system would also be built with a quick
nuclear Counter-Strike Mission likely to
run on solid fuel it was already on Kim
jong-un's wish list of military
modernizations outlined in its Five-Year
Plan along with a nuclear-powered
submarine analysts say reports so far
suggest despite stridesmaid 2022 was a
still unfulfilled year of military
targets for Pyongyang and that's North
Korea would Forge forward while
intimidating South Korea in response
South Korean president Yun sungir said
Seoul stood ready to punish any
provocation by the north his defense
Ministry warned any attempt to use
nuclear weapons would spell the end of
Kim jong-un's government
Eunice Kim Al Jazeera Seoul